our base two of eight we want to find
out what that equals what the value of
that log is and so there's a couple
different ways to look at this one way
to do it is to set it equal to some
value let's just say axe okay so we make
it into an equation and then what we can
do is we can do the inverse of taking
the log of eight and we can exponentiate
both sides so exponential functions and
logarithm functions they're inverses of
each other they undo or reverse or you
know cancel one another out so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to raise both
sides of this equation using base two
okay these are inverses of each other
they cancel one another out so we have a
equals two to the X power so two to what
power is eight three so this whole log
is equal to three okay now let's look at
another problem I'll show you another
way that teachers sometimes explain this
just in case your teacher does it this
way let's look at log base four of 1/16
okay log base four notice this four is a
subscript it's a little bit below the
line the 1/16 is on the same level as
the log and sometimes you'll have a
power up here so you actually have three
levels okay so you want to just be aware
of that so log base four or 1/16 equals
I'll just say question mark this time
now what some teachers do is they'll say
this is the base you're raising it to
this power and it equals 1/16 some
teachers will even go so far as to call
this like the circle technique or a
circle trick something like that so
you've got 4 to the question mark equals
1/16 4 to what power equals 1/16 4
squared is 16 but the negative takes the
reciprocal so this is actually going to
equal negative 2 so this whole log right
here this one right here log base 4 1/16
equals negative 2
okay let me show you another example
let's say we have log base 9 of 3 ok log
base 9 of 3 I'm just going to set this
equal to X I'm going to use the
technique I showed you in the first
example I'm going to exponentiate both
sides using the base 9 these are
inverses of each other they cancel 9 to
what power is 3 well we know that 9 to
the first is 9 that's too much but the
square root of 9 is 3 remember the
square root is the 1/2 power so this
whole thing is going to just equal 1/2
remember the denominator is the root the
numerators of power so X is 1/2 ok so
here are some examples of logs and how
to evaluate them
I'll show you one last example and then
we'll call it a wrap here for this video
so log base let's just say 2 of 8 cubed
okay so log base 2 of 8 cubed 8 is
actually 2 cubed so we could write this
as log base 2 of 2 cubed which is what 8
equals cubed now what do you do when you
have a power to a power that's right you
multiply the exponents so that's going
to be really like 9 ok so what we have
here is we have log base 2 of 2 to the
9th but remember how we said that logs
and exponential functions are inverses
of each other this is log base 2 this is
an exponential function with base 2
they're inverses they cancel one another
out so cancel cancel we just end up
getting 9 for our final answer so a few
different ways to approach logs again my
favorite is this technique of
exponentiating both sides I think it
makes
most sense it's like doing the opposite
if you add you subtract if you multiply
your divide if you square your square
root and if you have a log you can
exponentiate as long as you do it to
both sides to keep the equation balanced
and that's a good way to to evaluate
these logs so I'll see you in the next
video